y hablamos de la situación de los
territorios palestinos ocupados por
israel el más reciente informe de
amnistía internacional titulado del
apartheid de israel contra los
palestinos sistema cruel de dominación y
crimen contra la humanidad concluye que
las autoridades israelíes deben rendir
cuentas por cometer el crimen de
apartheid contra los palestinos la
investigación detalla como israel impone
un sistema de opresión y también
dominación contra el pueblo palestino
dondequiera que tenga el control sobre
sus derechos esto incluye a los
palestinos que viven en israel y
territorios palestinos ocupados así como
también refugiados en otros países para
ello entonces quiero dar la bienvenida a
nuestro primer invitado del día carlos
de las heras él es el portavoz sobre
israel y territorios para decirnos
ocupados de amnistía internacional
gracias carlos por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 también
está con nosotros en el estudio rosa
pérez más el rosa buenos días raúl
buenos días carlos queríamos empezar
pidiéndole que no se sintetice un poco
en los hechos en los que se basan para
denunciar este sistema de apartheid en
israel contra las personas palestinas
hola muy buenos días muchas gracias por
vuestra investigado por vuestra
invitación bueno en primer lugar los
hechos o las conclusiones a las que
llega el informe publicado por amnistía
internacional hace unas semanas es que
israel está cometiendo el crimen de lesa
humanidad que se define como apartheid
en que nos basamos para hablar de que
israel esté cometiendo apartheid pues
fundamentalmente lo que hemos hecho ha
sido
hacer un análisis desde la creación del
estado de israel en 1948 en el cual
hemos venido examinando las distintas
políticas puestas en marcha por los
distintos gobiernos que ha habido en
israel desde entonces se repiten una
serie de patrones que encajan con lo que
es la definición de apartheid patrones
como por ejemplo los desalojos forzosos
la demolición de las viviendas de los
palestinos las ejecuciones los
asesinatos extrajudiciales como por
ejemplo el de la periodista que citaba y
sant desde el de shiring
y además todo el sistema de control y de
segregación puesto en marcha por las
autoridades israelíes en que termina
esto termina en simplemente en la puesta
en marcha de toda una serie de políticas
que tienen un objetivo en favorecer a un
grupo social en este caso los israelíes
judíos sobre otro grupo red social que
en este caso serían la ciudadanía
palestina ahora carlos cuál es la
posición de israel digamos que dicen
sobre estas tierras ocupadas palestinas
además le pregunto en qué podría
terminar este conflicto y cuánto tiempo
podría durar vemos muy lejos lo que dijo
además el presidente yo bailé nace hace
pocos días de que volvió a decir que la
solución está en la creación de dos
estados usted que ha estudiado tanto
esos territorios y ese conflicto qué
opina al respecto
bueno es complicado si hablamos de
posibilidades de que termine el
conflicto
lamentablemente tenemos que ser
pesimistas y tenemos que ser pesimistas
porque hasta ahora las distintas
estrategias y líneas para la solución de
este conflicto no están funcionando y no
están funcionando básicamente por una
pasividad de por parte de la comunidad
internacional es decir la comunidad
internacional no puede permanecer al
margen de todas estas cuestiones que
están sucediendo en israel y en
territorios palestinos ocupados como no
lo está permaneciendo con lo que está
sucediendo en ucrania con ucrania y
rusia muchas veces nos acordamos del
conflicto entre israel y palestina
simplemente cuando aparecen en las
noticias pues el asesinato por ejemplo
de la periodista ceiling o que israel ha
invadido gaza o que la autoridad
nacional palestina está llevando a cabo
violaciones de derechos humanos dentro
de la franja de gaza
precisamente disculpa que la interrumpa
porque considera precisamente que la
comunidad internacional no interviene
del mismo modo como se ha movilizado
como usted estaba diciendo pues en el
caso de
bueno pues ahí hay toda una serie de
condicionantes en primer lugar una serie
de condicionantes históricos la creación
del estado de israel vino apoyada en
gran parte por la comunidad
internacional efectivamente había que
dar una solución y dar una respuesta a
los millones de personas judías que
fueron víctimas del holocausto y de las
posteriores violaciones de derechos
humanos de las que fueron objeto pero a
la creación del estado de israel también
provocó como hemos venido viendo a lo
largo de estos 70 años pues en multitud
de dificultades multitud de
preocupaciones sobre sobre los
enfrentamientos con las comunidades
árabes en segundo lugar tenemos que
destacar también que hay muchísimos
intereses económicos y en ese sentido
está muy bien que determinadas
autoridades como por ejemplo la unión
europea determinados países estados
miembros de la unión europea de vez en
cuando condenen algunas de las acciones
de israel como por ejemplo la expansión
de sus asentamientos en los territorios
palestinos ocupados pero al mismo tiempo
estos países están haciendo negocios con
israel negocio que en un momento dado
puede tener repercusiones negativas para
la población destino por ejemplo en
españa se están vendiendo armas al
gobierno al gobierno israelí está bien
que el gobierno español condene los
asentamientos israelíes pero si al mismo
tiempo estamos vendiendo las armas armas
que pueden ser utilizadas para violar
los derechos humanos pues entonces en
este sentido tenemos un problema y
tenemos que seguir trabajando para
solucionarlo claro y qué posibilidades
hay de que estas condenas verbales se
traduzcan precisamente en algún momento
en las sanciones pues económicas por
ejemplo para el rechazo a este apartheid
que ustedes denuncian
si en ese sentido distintos movimientos
por ejemplo ya externos incluso amnistía
internacional como por ejemplo el
movimiento bds que consiste en boicot
desinversión y sanciones que están
apoyando a la petición de la puesta en
marcha de una serie de sanciones para
israel también están promoviendo el
boicot por ejemplo de productos que se
venden en supermercados de todo el mundo
y que son procedentes de los territorios
palestinos ocupados en ese sentido
administ internacional lo que quiere es
defender el derecho de esta gente el
derecho de la gente que pertenece a bs a
llevar adelante sus campañas porque es
un derecho fundamental la libertad de
expresión y en segundo lugar en cuanto a
esas cuestiones también económicas pues
es necesaria una mayor intervención por
parte de naciones unidas unión europea
la organización de estados américanos
etcétera carlos estábamos también
conversando precisamente también con
rosa pérez antes de esta conversación
con usted
sobre el asesinato de la periodista
irina bu agile no que fue esto tan
mediático como usted lo dijo puso otra
vez sobre la mesa estas diferencias y
estas disputas que siempre ha habido
entre estos a territorios le pregunto
cómo quede entonces la imagen de israel
en el mundo
al exterior digamos la comunidad
internacional y además y las autoridades
israelíes les importaría no si tienes la
para les importaría cómo se ven no
exactamente quería añadir a la pregunta
de mi compañero raúl que sí sí a israel
exactamente le importa su imagen pues
frente al mundo no después de que todos
viéramos por ejemplo pues la
intervención de la policía israelí
durante el funeral de la periodista pero
eso mismo iba a comentar las imágenes
hablan por sí solas de las imágenes de
la policía reprimiendo el sepelio
reprimiendo el entierro de la periodista
y de la periodista palestina hablan por
sí solas se israel esto le debe de
importar o le debe de afectar sobre todo
en cuanto a su imagen internacional
en mi opinión si en mi opinión es algo
que le afecta y aquí es importante como
comentábamos al principio no hablar de
que este asesinato es una muestra más de
ese crimen de lesa humanidad que es el
apartheid todo el mundo es consciente de
que en sudáfrica hubo un régimen de
apartheid y cuando la comunidad
internacional empezó a conocer a
reconocer perdón esta situación como
constituyente de apartheid comenzaron a
llegar avances y afortunadamente con el
paso de los años y la solución pues
bueno pues que estuvo está estuvo mucho
más cercana nuestro objetivo ahora mismo
es ese mismo que la comunidad
internacional reconozca públicamente que
lo que está sucediendo por parte de
israel hacia hacia la población
palestina es un crimen de apartheid